you gave a lot of credit to I think
Caltech and MIT for some of the
technical developments like within this
project is there some interesting things
you can speak to like
at the low level of some cool stuff that
had to be solved like what are we
talking about I'm a software engineer so
okay all of this I have so much more
respect for everything done here than
anything I've ever done so it's just
Coast so so I'll give you an example of
doing uh
uh mechanical engineering at a better at
a at a basically mechanical engineering
and geology and maybe at a level uh so
what are we what's the problem the
problem is the following that I've given
you this picture of an instrument that I
by some magic I can make good enough to
measure this very short distance but
then I put it down here it won't work
and the reason it doesn't work is that
the Earth itself is moving all over the
place all the time you don't realize it
it seems pretty good to you I get it but
it's moving all the time so somehow it's
moving so much that you we can't deal
with it we happen to be trying to do the
experiment here on Earth but we can't
deal with it so we have to make the
instrument isolated from the Earth
oh no at the frequencies we're at we've
got to float it that's a mechanical
that's an engineering problem not a
physics problem so when you actually
like uh we're doing we're having a
conversation on a podcast right now
there's uh and people who record music
work with this you know how to create an
isolated room
and they usually build a room within a
room
but that's still not isolated in fact
they say it's impossible to truly
isolate from sound from noise and stuff
like that but that that that's like one
step of
millions that you took as building a
room inside a room because you basically
have to isolate all now this is actually
an easier problem it's just have to do
it really well so the making a clean
room is really a tough problem because
you have to put a room inside a room
yeah
so this is this is really simple
engineering or physics okay so what do
you have to do how do you isolate
yourself from the from the earth yes
first we work at uh we're not looking at
all frequencies for gravitational waves
we're looking at particular frequencies
that you can deal with here on Earth
so what are frequencies would those be
you were just talking about frequencies
I mean we know by Evolution our bodies
know it's the audio band
Okay the reason our ears work where they
work is that's where the Earth isn't
going making too much noise okay so the
reason our ears work the way they work
is because this is where it's quiet
that's right so if you go to if you go
to one Hertz instead of 10 Hertz it's
the Earth is it's really moving around
so so somehow we live in a what we call
the audio band it's tens of Hertz to
thousands of Hertz that's where we live
that's where we live okay
if we're going to do an experiment on
the earth I might as well do this it's
the same frequency that's where the
Earth is the quietest so we have to work
in that frequency so we're not looking
at all frequencies okay
so the solution for the for the shaking
of the earth to get rid of it is pretty
mundane if we do the same thing that you
do uh to make your car drive smoothly
down the road so what happens when your
car goes over a bump
early cars did that they bounced right
okay but you don't feel that in your car
so what happened to that energy you
can't just disappear energy so we have
these things called shock absorbers in
the car what they do is they absorb they
take the the thing that went like that
and they basically can't get rid of the
energy but they move it to very very low
frequency
so what you feel isn't you feel like oh
shhh smoothly okay all right so uh
we also work at this frequency so if we
so we basically why why don't we have to
do anything other than shock absorbers
so we made the world's fanciest shock
absorbers
okay
uh not just like in your car where
there's one layer of them they're just
the right squishiness and so forth
they're better than what's in the cars
and we have four layers of it so
whatever shakes and gets through the
first layer we treat it in a second
third so some mechanical engineering
problems yeah I said so it said there's
no weird tricks to it like uh like a
chemistry type thing or no no just well
the right squishing a seat or I need the
right material inside and ours look like
little Springs but they're Springs
there's Springs so like legitimately
like shock absorbers yeah
what okay okay
and this is now experimental physics at
the at its limit okay so you do this and
we make the world's fanciest shock
absorber it's just mechanical
engineering
just mechanic this is hilarious but we
didn't yes we weren't good enough to
discover gravitational waves um
so uh so we did another we added another
feature and it's something else that
you're uh
aware of probably have one
and that is to get rid of noise you've
probably noise which is you don't like
and that's the same principle that's in
these little bows uh uh earphones
canceling noise canceling so uh so how
do they work they basically you go on an
airplane and they sense the ambient
noise from the engines and cancel it
because it's just the same over and over
again they cancel it and when the
stewardess comes and asks you whether
you want coffee or a tea or a drink or
something you are fine because she's not
ambient she's a signal so are we talking
about active canceling like where are
they actually canceling
so this is you okay so another don't
tell me you have active canceling uh on
this yeah besides the show yeah so we
had this so inside this array of shock
absorbers yeah we you asked for some
interesting this is awesome so inside
this it's harder than the the earphone
problem but it's just engineering we
have to see measure not just at the
uh engines still made noise but the
Earth is shaking it's moving in some
Direction so we have to actually tell
not only that there's noise and cancel
it but what direction it's from so we
put this array of seismometers inside
this array of shock absorbers and
measure the residual motion and its
direction
and we put little actuators that push
back against it and cancel it
awesome so you have the actuators and
you have the thing that is sensing the
the vibrations and then you have the
actual actuators that adjust for that
and do some imperfect synchrony yeah
what if it all works right and so how
much do we reduce the shaking of the
Earth
I mean one part in 10 to the 12th
one part instead what gets through us is
one part in 10 to the 12th
that's pretty big reduction you don't
need that in your car but that's what we
do and so that's how isolated we are
from the earth and that was the biggest
uh I I say technical problem outside of
the physics instrument the
interferometer oh that's a weird
question here you may get very
poetically and humorously it's saying
it's just a mechanical engineering
problem
but is this one of the
biggest
Precision
mechanical engineering efforts ever I
mean this seems exceptionally difficult
it is and so it took a long time and uh
I think
nobody seems to challenge the statement
that this is the most Precision precise
instrument it's ever been built ligo
I just I wonder what like listening to
Led Zeppelin sounds on this thing
because it's so isolated I mean this is
like uh I don't know no background no no
back it's wow
wow
wow that so when you were first
conceiving this um
I would probably uh if I was
knowledgeable enough kind of uh laugh
off the possibility this is even
possible I'm sure
like how many people believe that this
is possible did you believe oh uh I did
um I didn't know that we need for sure
that we needed active when we started we
did just passive but we were doing the
tests to develop the active
to add as a second stage which we ended
up needing
um but there was a lot of you know now
now there was a lot of skepticism a lot
of us especially astronomers felt that
money was being wasted as we were also
expensive doing what I told you is not
cheap so it was kind of controversial it
was funded by the National Science
Foundation
can you just Linger on this just for a
little longer the actuator thing the act
of canceling
um
do you remember like little experiments
that were done along the way to prove to
the team to themselves that this is even
possible
so from our because I work with quite a
bit of robots and to me the idea that
you could do it this precisely
is a humbling and embarrassing frankly
because like this is another level of
precision that I can't even
um because robots are a mess and this is
basically one of the most precise robots
ever
right so like can you is there um yeah
do you have any like small scale
experiments that were done that's just
me this is possible yeah and larger
scale we made we made uh tests uh
that also has to be in vacuumed too but
we made test chambers that had this
system in it our first mock of this
system that so we could test it
uh and uh
optimize it and make it work but it's
just a mechanical engineering problem
okay
uh and humans are just eight descendants
I got you I got you uh is there any
video of this like uh some kind of
educational purpose visualizations of
this act of canceling and uh I don't
think so
I mean is this does this live on
well we work for parts of it for the
active canceling we worked with for the
instruments for the sensor and
instruments we worked with uh uh a small
company and near where you are because
it was our MIT people that got them that
were you know interested in the problem
because they thought they might be able
to commercialize it for making staple
tables to make microelectronics for
example which are limited by how stable
the table is I mean at this point it's a
little expensive so you never know never
know where this leads okay